you should just be yourself right i mean
i i take pride in the fact that i didn't
give
what anybody thought or said i was just
going to be myself i find if i don't get
enough sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
that way you just have to develop the
ability to say no and
and and uh do it a few times want to be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
lessons from elon musk warren buffett
and
other billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one manage your time well with
elon musk
you're running you're ceo of two
companies you're chairman of solar city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep uh yeah
sometimes not enough
sleep is really great uh because because
if
i find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
are that way um
and and also like i try to sort of
figure out what's the
right amount of sleep because like i
found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it
that would get less done because um
my mental acuity would be affected um
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours
on average per night um that's not too
bad
yeah right and any other tips on average
though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously
i mean do you do you find i mean i know
you're up here monday tuesday is it
all tesla when you're up in silicon
valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a sort of um
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email
during um interstitial periods like
you're in a car you're walking in the
bathroom everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake
and uh and so that's really helpful to
have
email for spacex and tesla integrated on
my phone
and then uh
and then it's just you have to apply a
lot of hours to actual working
actually working so the way i generally
do it is i'll be
uh working at spacex
on monday and then monday night flight
to the bay area
uh spent tuesday and wednesday at the
bay area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night spend thursday and
friday
at spacex um in in
the last several months then i would fly
back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
uh or spend saturday at tesla and sunday
at spacex
lesson number two be comfortable saying
no with warren buffett
can you help us understand how to
cultivate how to cultivate that
mindset of being comfortable saying no
being comfortable delegating this is
something that
we found with our members is especially
difficult for young women
it's tough um and we'd love to just hear
your take on that and maybe any advice
you have to share about that i met bill
goods
bill gates in 1991 and when i did it
we had a great time talking he thought
he was going to hate it and i
i wasn't too keen on it either and about
10 hours later we were still talking but
what really got him was when i pulled
out this little date book
i'm probably the only guy in the united
states with one of these still what oh
you've got that
and i just flipped through it and you
know there's there's probably nothing in
it and bill was really impressed by that
and uh you've got to keep control of
your time and
and you won't keep control of your time
unless you can say no
you can't let other people set your
agenda in life and of course
i know i'm in a very fortunate position
on that because i can
and in another way i'm not so fortunate
because more people ask me for things
and and and they're and they're usually
friends and they say well
can't you just make this one talk or
attend this one graduation or whatever
it may be
uh you know you you've gotta you just
have to develop the ability to say no
and
and and uh do it a few times uh i mean
you know the woman can't say no she's in
trouble right
right and i mean is this something that
becomes easier over time or how did you
i don't think it gets a lot easier no it
is it's there's a couple there's a few
things that really just are
uncomfortable enough i've
the thing i like the thing i dislike the
most
the the only thing i really dislike in
connection with my job is if i have to
fire somebody
i mean that does not get easy for the
easier for me
as life has gone wrong and saying no is
not like firing people but it's got a
little bit of the same aspect to it
it's not easy to say no particularly to
a friend
uh but i will have every day three or
four or five requests to do something
and i
i can't do them all you know and uh
but i'm not promising it gets easier but
but just keep doing it right otherwise
other people will be running your life
lesson number three listen to your
customers with jeff bezos
you shop on amazon yeah and uh
if you have something the service you
don't like yeah so do you just pick up
the phone
call your team of 700 000 people and
tell them i don't like this change this
or
you know what i do so um i don't do this
it doesn't happen that often but if i
get a
delivery that i don't like maybe they're
like was packaged or something we have
regular
meetings of the senior executive team
and i bring the box
to the meeting and when i walk in i
haven't done this
in a while it's been a while but when i
bring in a box
everybody in the room is like oh no he's
bringing in a box
because it's always some problem but
really the way i get
feedback is to is primarily from
my email address is very well known and
i keep it well known
and i get hundreds and hundreds of
emails every day from customers
and they always have something
interesting to say
when something goes wrong because we
have hundreds of millions of customers
around the world and no matter how good
we are
we can still be better you can always be
better
customers have a divine discontent and
they teach you if you listen to
customers
so we watch for that and we see patterns
and we can find places where it's not
working something's going wrong
and that's really how i get the feedback
is from customer
input and often you know in all caps
angry you ruined my child's birthday
because the gift didn't show up on time
and we take that and what you really
want to do
is you take that it's an anecdote it's a
single example
but you need to find the root cause what
went wrong
deep inside the system how did this
happen because then you can fix it for
everyone
so that particular problem will never
happen again you don't just fix the
symptom you have to fix the root cause
and that's been the secret to our
operational success for 20 years
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below there's my
two and a half year old son
sitting on the floor in a bunch of
clothes and there's a note
can't handle it anymore better off with
you good luck
i'm gone you can be incredibly
productive incredibly creative and
credibly free
when you take control of your time i've
always been passionate
some people thought you know it's it's
more ocd than anything else
lesson number four be grateful with
oprah winfrey
i wake up in the morning what you do and
the first thing i say is
thank you that's my first thing even
before i'm awake even before my eyes are
really fully open
i i say thank you i can feel the
gratitude like
i'm still here i'm in a body thank you
so much i thank you for that
and then i go through the letting the
dogs out the whole
you know brushing your teeth and all
that stuff and then i
have either silence or prayer or
something that acknowledges
that i'm still here i do not reach for
that phone first that's your problem
that's my problem that's your problem
lesson number five be creative with
jesse itzler
when you get a 1 000 on your sat
i probably got like a 980 i've convinced
myself that i broke a thousand
creativity becomes a survival skill it's
a necessity to get into the door
to interview to sell everything for me
revolved around
creativity so one day at the recording
studio i walk in
and there's a cassette sitting on the
music board and it's the cassette that
changed my life
the cassette was by an artist a rat
pioneer named dana dane
dana was a brooklyn-born artist his
first album was one of my favorite
albums and this was an advanced copy in
the late 80s that nobody
or nobody had sitting there i wanted to
listen to it so i asked the engineer if
i could borrow the cassette
and i would bring the cassette back
after i listened to it he said sure
a couple of days later i'm on my way to
los angeles to visit a friend
i'm listening to it in my sony walkman
if anyone remembers those
sony walkman yeah and when i'm on the
plane i read that the owner of delicious
finals favorite
artist this is a big label tone loch and
young his favorite artist
is dana dane so when i land in
california
i cold called delicious vinyl i get all
the way up to the assistant of this guy
she has no idea what i'm talking about
i'm talking very fast like a new yorker
i have dana's tape i know mike's a fan
of dana she puts me on hold
she comes back two minutes later and she
says dana if you can be here at two
o'clock
mike ross would love to meet you dana
will be there at two o'clock
two o'clock comes the dana's a brooklyn
boring guy like i said african-american
goldtooth
not me i pushed the now a good friend of
mine though
pushed the button they said i said hey
i'm dana here from micros oh
mike is expecting you dana come right in
i walk in they escort me into the
office loke's record young's record he's
got this funky candle going they sit me
down
i'm sitting there i'm waiting no idea
what's going to happen
in walks mike ross and says to me not as
politely
who in the world are you there's a
famous quote by harry truman
if you can't convince them confuse them
it works so far so i start saying oh i
work at the same studio as dana i know
you're a fan of dana he must be late
he has an advanced tape can i put in my
cassette that i did at dana studio
you have a cassette what do you do i
wrap
huh put it in put in my cassette
and he says the four words that every
artist struggling artist wants to hear
who's your lawyer i don't have a lawyer
i have a dad so i give him my dad's
number my dad owns a plumbing
my dad owns a plumbing supply house in
minneola
i call my father when we leave i said
dad i think i just got a record deal if
someone calls you
we got our foot in the door we're gonna
figure the rest out later
get all the documents that started a
journey
of getting my foot in the door and
figuring it out
later a key thing in creativity starting
the process
trusting the process and letting it
evolve because if you don't get your
foot in the door if you don't start
nothing happens i did it with a company
called marquee jet we sold it to warren
buffett i did it with our company's eco
coconut water we sold it to coca-cola
lesson number six just be yourself with
mark cuban
you have lived your life as an
iconoclast and in a way that's a
template for other people but in a way
it isn't
so in other words how much you've got an
ordinary person ordinary man or woman
how much of an iconoclast could you or
should you be like mark cuban
oh i don't care just you should just be
yourself right i mean i i take pride in
the fact that i didn't give
when anybody thought or said i was just
going to be myself and
you know on my dad's son on my mom's son
my brother's brother
you know um alexis alyssa and jake's
father
tiffany's husband this you know i just
try to do the best like everybody else i
mean i've been blessed
you know like i say all the time i'm the
luckiest guy in the world and i just
try not to take it for granted i try to
enjoy every minute
and i think now as i've gotten a little
bit older i try to give a little bit
more back than i have before and
and try to help more people and i you
know in terms of whatever
if anybody else finds himself in my
position just enjoy the moment enjoy
every minute of it
i mean i guess my question is are you a
role model for people in society
i don't know i mean i never thought of
it i mean it's not something i try to be
i just try to be myself you know i just
try to
to to help where i can do what i can
be a good dad and you know
i i'm not trying to be something for
somebody else just myself
and lesson number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is believe with john paul de jouria at
what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for
what was the point where you guys said
hmm like let's do this like what was the
well
we were planning to do it because i knew
the business
i was in marketing sales and structure
and had connections with uh
product development and i didn't do hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world very advanced in what
he did
however he didn't do business it was a
perfect combination
together we're just the best of friends
and we knew we could do it uh
obviously we started out with nothing we
made the decision let's just let's just
make
this happen and as you will see and your
guests will see when they look at good
fortune the movie
and it's on itunes it's on amazon all
those when they
look at it it's the whole story of
starting in america
with nothing a couple times and making
things happen because of what you
believe in
but the important thing is even we had
nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first company to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state
wow or other things we did why not shake
your hand today sure you betcha but i
applaud you
that's awesome it's still going on that
one now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through that's what we do here
believe nation
we get motivated but then we do
something about it
and when you commit to other people you
increase your chances even further of
following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video and then what is your plan of
action around
for this week put it down in the
comments below because i want to
celebrate
you speaking of learning from lessons
you've been around a lot of incredible
entrepreneurs
and i know you did a reality show with
richard branson
says 10 12 years ago you said yes what
was that like and what's been a big
lesson you've learned from him and what
was the show
and what'd you learn yeah the show was
called the rebel billionaire and it was
the apprentice version richard branson's
version of that
they were looking for 16 entrepreneurs
so i'm like hey i'm an entrepreneur i
want to do this and i really wanted to
meet richard
i sort of had set intentions out there
that i was going to
manifest him becoming a friend in my
life so when i heard about the show i
was like oh this is interesting this
might be how this happens
so i applied for it and um
uh it was wild so it's how big how big
was spanx at the time was it really well
known was it like just kind of
it was pretty i mean it was four years
in it was doing great
yeah multiple seven figures yeah my
lawyers begged me not to do it they're
like what are you doing you own this
company you're going to do a reality
show i was like i just want to know
richard i just feel like this is a
chance
so um so yeah and
all the business challenges took place
around the world in different cities
and instead of if you didn't win the
business challenge going into a board
room to get fired you had to do
a crazy stunt like a world record
breaking stunt because richard is
obviously
like a huge adrenaline junkie guy so
um in addition to being an amazing
entrepreneur and the very first day of
filming i had to climb the side of a hot
air balloon at 9 000 feet in the air on
a dangling rope ladder and have tea
climb to the top and have tea
on top of the balloon with richard
that's insane it's insane
what did you guys talk about on top oh
my god i talked about like how do we get
down and that's what he said you climbed
back down i was like
what i didn't think about that it was so
scary yeah oh my gosh
yeah so it took me 48 minutes to climb
to the top
it's at the height of a 17-story
building and the dangling rope ladder
was just like hanging out into the abyss
of nothingness
wasn't anchored to anything so i'm like
climbing it
and um there's camera that was the first
day of filming
so two months later i know i like
cameras up there
yes helicopters circling
probably probably i had to do all these
crazy stunts the next stop i had to do
is i had to jump
off the side of the victoria falls gorge
in africa
on a with a bungee cord attached to me
and my
guy on my team was dangling on a wire
on a crane 10 feet out from the cliff
and each person had to come up and stand
there and you couldn't run and jump
and you had to stand still and jump and
if he caught you
you were okay and they'd put you back on
the cliff and if not you fell 385 feet
on a bungee cord and so i am beyond
terrified of heights it's like
one of my i'm so afraid of heights i cry
on airplanes still during takeoff a lot
of times
and i was one of the only people to make
the jump richard didn't make the jump
all these other guys that were like
amazing athletes didn't make the jump
and i like to talk about this because i
always talk about aiming high
and the importance of aiming high in
life and then i think all of us we don't
aim high enough
and so watch where you're aiming and
that that's
saying you know if you shoot for the
moon if you miss you're at least with
the stars
and afterwards everyone was like sarah
how did you make that jump you're
literally like the only contestant look
at you i said
well i was aimed at the pulley six feet
above
his head where were you aiming and i
aimed
i didn't even look at him i aimed six
feet above his head and i landed at his
waist and he caught me and everybody
else was aiming at his face and landed
at his feet
and missed amazing so it's like a really
just
poignant example of the importance of
aiming high
in all areas of life yeah
[Music]
if you want seven more lessons from how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy
it continue to believe and i'll see you
there two pizza teams is something that
we've been preaching at amazon
almost from the very beginning and it's
a simple idea which is
we were so close